[Música]
eu sou professora que se chama aos pais
muito obrigado pelo convite
é fantástico isto é deus o professor dá
às segundas feiras
isto é são professoras diante e quando
me convidam para vir falar se sobre o
meu trabalho sobre o meu percurso e
acima de tudo somos uma coisa que chama
futuro o futuro uma forma clara é uma
experiência que nós vamos temos no nosso
dia a dia eo futuro eo futuro já que o
que eu vou trazer
foi um trabalho que objetiva e com o
trabalho do futuro mas é incrível ontem
ã rã seguiu uma nova imagem do festival
da canção ele o trabalho vai ser
exatamente sobre isso falar sobre isso e
futuro já é o novo
a nova imagem do festival marcação mas o
que eu vou fazer aqui exatamente são
experiências que eu sou eu sou em quatro
delas o viseu e com ventanias botas que
nos contra as minhas origens e incrível
porque não consegui desviar daquilo que
desde a génese das minhas formas de
pensado nesse rodeado de sérgio detento
meu trabalho e vou mostrar os
relacionados com o mar e provavelmente
isso é uma coisa boa porque esse
distanciamento geográfico é o leva a que
as pessoas questionem está ensinando não
são um pouco mais clara é uma coisa que
nos é tão familiar estar atentas
aprendemos a gostar e é perceber como é
que a emater i para pra fazer um
trabalho que foi proposto foi posto em
que planeta você já deve saber que ser o
salvador sobral foi o grande responsável
lula ganhou o festival da canção e toim
evitado nós temos que ter um festival da
canção
efe frf trio e portanto contra portugal
por lisboa é ser eu o espaço para
mostrar que essa coisa é um tema que o
tema era o marcio e o marcel é eu gosto
imenso de memórias e joão beirão fluido
eu vi o pedro marques marcinho foi um
veículo e sempre foi uma na forma de
estar mais próximo com o meu espaço
natural eu sou mas tanto a água e no
início
foi este o motivo que eu vou e ainda bem
que o tema era relacionado com o país à
beira mar plantado que o mar era o ponto
de partida para o motivo é do festival
da canção portanto o início é mesmo o
mar
o márcio relacionado e que nós sempre
tivemos uma relação muito próxima com
marcas só coar mesmo tempo os
cumprimentos esta esse lado mais
fantástico do que estava no mundo
desconhecido com monstros com
imaginários as nossas imaginações
levaram os grandes e outras descobertas
e este meu trabalho
foi exatamente eu sou aqui sabemos que
via um festival da canção
havia um tema que 111 mil em espécie de
111 klein uma palavra que era ao aborto
quer para trazer todos os tempos é uma
forma de integrar se e de receber muitos
países muitas culturas muita música
todos juntos para celebrar num grande
festival e numa forma inclusive nós
trouxemos todos cá e criamos este clima
do órgão isso a morte foi exatamente
isso foi trazer toda a gente cá
e nessa minha pesquisa nesta minha
procura consegue exatamente a pensar e
ver onde é que nós poderíamos isso
encontrar é bater e provocar o trabalho
mas vocês vão perceber onde é que se
encaixam no futuro tanto estes lados
este imaginário eu fui pra casa
foi juiz livros laio relacionado com
marco assinado com os nossos
descobrimentos inclusive - eu ea praia
passear em grandes caminhadas no modo a
refletir e pensar um pouco
nisto o que é que nos leva a pensar
nesta imaginário que o mar não estou
sempre escolhas pesquisas e
inclusivamente perceber que o homem
esteve sempre ligado mas só perguntei
stenson tempo segurando o riso mas foi
sempre uma na relação muito próxima do
homem e este motivo esta forma de sentir
o mar presentes em roma é que o mar
seria sempre o meu ponto de partida e
não só
além do caso relacionado com o mar nós
temos os poetas e outra matéria que não
vou a pesquisa foi exatamente essa a da
literatura e os lados não só das artes
plásticas foto todos os os formulários
de receitas que vem em torno da imagem e
das mensagens que os temos diariamente
visuais
temos a literatura aquilo que eu vou
trazer aqui exatamente um poeta entre
vários que marcou imenso que o caminhão
scania que fala exatamente desde
pequenas coisas de 500 pessoas que nos
encontramos numa destas pequenas
maravilhas que estão no óxi nosso olhar
e outras não
eu tô é que o poema dito em inglês
porque eu fiz esta apresentação no
estrangeiro mas eu escrevi em português
e ditta para uma amiga e colega é
inglesa que tem uma voz fantástica que
gostava que vocês acompanharem o caso
desta idéia de que o marido de uma
poesia é alguma coisa que está sempre
ligado a nós e se meter na minha
conversa convosco é pense um pouco
é uma coisa que eu quero partilhar que é
perceber que o trabalho tem que ser
feita com emissão e no sal tem que nos
temos que perceber que ela tem que estar
sempre presente na nossa vida é uma
forma de falar já foi do futuro pensa em
que para o futuro presente e futuro
investimento passado
a emissão tem que acompanhar de outra
coisa importante é que eu digo várias
vezes meus alunos ea curiosidade
vocês devem ser curioso
essa curiosidade passa por tudo ser
curioso é ser sábio na vida do poeta em
questão que eu sabia que vocês água
mineral de cobre sem fala desta maneira
assim o país à distância diz a tam vai
clicar de pink chelsea cole mas grande
parte sei lá e tem ainda a multa é uma
mensagem que nos transmite na distância
do nosso olhar
temos possibilidades de uma coisa que
está simplesmente que a relação mas
sensível e sensorial com que o currículo
neste caso com o mar
é uma viagem
o mar leva nos a uma viagem como é vida
tende para uma viagem eu sinto o poeta
já estão na fila atletas que mais se
usar animais fizeram me disse uma coisa
muito curta que em outra coisa que vocês
têm que ter para o futuro que não
desisto
ana com a estrada começa joanas gostar
três fases é uma coisa que vocês têm que
ter presentes o coronel
é uma questão de acreditar outra questão
para o futuro é crença acreditar no que
você acha que o marília viagem tudo isso
levou a uma viagem uma viagem por várias
vários momentos de emoção digitação de
pesquisa de uma grande responsabilidade
que este ano estamos a falar do melhor
futebol mas a falar de uma coisa que vou
ter com estou aqui pronto vocês disposto
objetivo está disposto a mostrar as
fraquezas nos 3 nossas as nossas formas
novas tics e aqui é é uma coisa que
teria uma visibilidade ia ter uma
finalidade portal tem essa
responsabilidade é que estou aqui fazer
tinha que fazer várias vezes
apresentando pessoas que não falam
português e então é tá só por isto
perceber que esta viagem tem que ser
feita também de apresentá-los que o
mundo de história faz parte das nossas
viagens com este senhor com os registros
gráficos que os faziam aqui com soul amy
pesquisa a pesquisa da pro da
iconografia daquilo que nos leva r criar
um mundo dessas viagens são imagens
fantásticas imagens de impressões que as
pessoas tiveram como longa vida ao longo
do
desconhecido e daquilo que é o desvio
encontrado em mundos desconhecidos e
isto era o meu mundo desconhecido e
entrar num mundo novo quero ver o
futebol eu nunca recebi nada o que eu li
azul não gostava não viam o festival e
aprendeu a gostar de aprender a perceber
que é um mundo muito é diferente e acima
tudo muito variado e que nos leva os
incríveis e artur - o mar estava no
nosso passado em nosso imaginário
destacar novamente
estamos novamente e voltar pra eu
estamos virados de costas para o mar em
voltar nos prestar novamente ligados ao
vivo em lisboa e de repente toda a zona
ribeirinha pessoa ser novamente uma
forma te novartis suas famílias
skeeter software todos eles estão
virados à zona ribeirinha a uma
necessidade dessa aproximação do márcio
e essa aproximação foi bom importante
para eu dizer a 5 bairro e que que eu
vou buscar a mesma coisa eu tô sexto
filme que são coisas que os levam coisas
que nós fomos perdendo estamos
reabilitando novamente provavelmente não
esta chave oeste este barco mas terão
outros mas há essa relação que existe
uma coisa que puxa leva
é que é essencial que nós temos nosso
próprio dia a dia são homens e pessoas
que trabalham em grandes empresas que
trabalham com ele dez anos
estamos agora vamos pensar analisar e
fuzilar para o festival
todos estes temas estavam à volta disto
eram as minhas preocupações na hora que
eu ia buscar as coisas como referência e
fui à vida associados que ver matéria
que vir realmente um motivo tinha ver um
evento qualquer para começar a trabalhar
o jogo tipos
a imagem que o tudo o que as outras
pessoas disseram que o fundo e criam ver
bolas então afinal de contas o que é
imagem do festival 2018 numa passeata
que eu fiz eu gosto muito de trás a zona
da costa vicentina que dá pra isso
muitos unitárias e obstruiu passear com
um livro e gosta de estar na água mas
sou daquelas pessoas ficam sem apanhar
sol standard e de repente se existiu
nenhuma dessas passeatas que também dos
oceanos uma coisa que provavelmente nós
não vimos não são os pais
o mais óbvio é buscar o país deve buscar
os meios e essa corretora
mas não fica uma coisa está longe mas
que somos nós e que eu fiz aqui o poeta
aí vocês me desculpem mas o crescimento
de plantas aqui pra vocês
o peru está vendo que é fantástico maré
longe mas nós somos o vento
essa liberdade criativa aquilo que nós
podemos ter e por tantos na liberdade
criativa e daquilo que provavelmente não
está ao alcance do nosso olhar onde é
que o brasil para fazer a imagem do
futebol bonito clinton porque o plâncton
que o plâncton é tão diverso tão
fantástico
então misturar de formas curvas que são
organismos para além de serem
fundamentais para a nossa vida são
diferentes e nessa diversidade que vem
os leões fazem os ingleses franceses
saem todos juntos todos maravilhados em
torno da música e é isso que eu quero
para se acha a imagem do futebol na
diversidade na forma e na cor e na luz e
da luz porque não é possível que o rei
dos planetários que está aqui inseridas
no projeto mas é exatamente isso
foi nestes alimentos orgânicos que não
vemos é que nós atacantes temos que são
essenciais para a vida porque o peixinho
que você escola e não só
só existe com estes rendimentos existem
e portanto aconselharam o assunto é
pintor desenhador artista plástico amada
igreja que desisto design é o nosso
entendimento é fixar em instantes no
nosso entendimento rápido claro e
simples e é exatamente isso que saí daí
ele vai continuar sendo desenhados
baseados em que nos momentos dos nossos
da nossa história nos padrões e nem
clube e iconografia que existe na cidade
cansadas as pretas
depois começaram as reformas começaram a
surgir as formas que vieram em design e
eu gosto de sonhar eu sou um pintor de
ser profissional na rtp
eu gostei o design passa exatamente por
isso documentos que levam à criação da
imagem
pra mim é que está o futuro ministro
turco está exatamente se as perspectivas
que nós fomos quase no original esse
nosso colega luiz disse que nunca tinha
conseguido um computador e também não
era dela sempre que sair
e era computadores nem vê los e ter
feito tudo aquilo que fui aprendendo
estive tentado entrar em prática o
iphone eo papel que são dois momentos do
futuro e do passado mas a nossa geração
do do futuro ea ação do presentes as
coisas se misturam se ele falar do
futuro vocês entendem melhor que ninguém
que o futuro é o que eu disse no início
é uma questão de serem curiosos ponto
vou adiantar isso foi a apresentação do
logótipo oficial
fui por cenário que tem som pensou não
têm bom enfim é este uma opção e foi o
vídeo da apresentação da imagem
a visão é foram filmados
outra coisa que eu tenho de dizer esse
trabalho é um trabalho individual de
trabalho do grupo é uma coisa que vocês
têm que perceber que esse trabalho nunca
se faz persie uma só pessoa são centenas
as pessoas que nos ajudam é que as
coisas aconteçam
ela está com essa sempre o design começa
sempre exatamente por o início esta
apresentação foi a única polêmica assim
o perdão porque ficaram todas elas igual
acho que um desenho foi a primeira
reação e os nulos nas redes sociais foi
tudo muito esquisito porteiro vira uma
coisa desenhada e ficaram todos ficaram
impressionados que estão habituados são
coisas muito a etec e um foi uma das
coisas que disse na apresentação foi eu
sou pintor e não fugir isso portanto é
nisso que eu quero em seguir que é no
design e no design pois foi adaptada em
várias coisas em várias situações e
cartazes os autores porque a tensão o
euro futebol não passa só pelo
espetáculo em si é uma cidade que se
veste de imagens a uma idéia a idéia do
ouro de principal que se multiplicou os
outros por causa da universidade foi o
primeiro festival que teve não umas três
motivos que estiveram assim na cidade da
ilha é definida sua cor era criar
grandes alamedas coloridas de cor que
foram adaptadas em várias situações no
metro
nas cidades em pernas
o atentado acabou e pronto
peço desculpa eu estive no tempo não é é
a desse imenso i uma próxima
oportunidade
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]